I am present I have sensors
holy West you're not an easy man to find
no that's the point of meditation who
are you my name is Rick hunter I am
trying to save the universe and I need
your help
hey everybody its charlie we got a freak
out about this it finally happened they
brought Wally West on to the Waverider
if you're just finding me for the first
time I will be doing videos for all of
the Wally legends episodes which is
basically the rest of the season so be
sure to subscribe to get everything
and there is a flash ring giveaway going
on that I'll explain at the end of the
video I was afraid that they weren't
going to include him in the episode but
he was listed on IMDB so I figured they
would just tag him at the end so it got
to like the last couple of minutes then
sure enough
excuse me Wally West I'm here to invite
you on an adventure across all of space
and time in my TARDIS so just careful
for spoilers from the episode if you
haven't seen it yet largely it was a
zari episode doing groundhogs day with
them actually having done an Abba
episode before the events of the episode
actually pick up so when they all roll
in at the beginning of the episode
before they go into groundhogs day mode
they're wearing Abba costumes so most of
you probably know who that band is let's
do top 10 WTF Easter eggs and I'll talk
about Wally West because obviously next
week's episode he'll be around for the
entire episode number 10 the team rolls
in wearing their Abba costumes it turns
out that Napoleon was the anachronism
that they were trying to fix so they had
to pretend to be the band ABBA so that's
why they were referencing that song
Waterloo because that's an Abba song but
the Battle of Waterloo was where they
were taking Napoleon Bonaparte back to
zari also said Mamma Mia here I go again
referencing that song and then the audio
glitched out when heatwave was talking
about the song that was stuck in his
head but that was another Abba song to
number nines or he gets the goose billed
on her and begin groundhogs day so she
just goes to a couple of funny montages
nobody believes her she finds out about
all the crazy stuff that the group is
doing
turns out named vixens sneak off to do
it while they're on missions that's
actually a pretty serious infraction ray
also says that Nate has a stash of
psychedelic drugs lying around somewhere
we learn about heat waves donuts he
always has food lying around though
there's never a moment when heat wave is
not either thinking about food or
putting food in his mouth number eight
it gets
even weirder heat way of doing laundry
that's weird so this is mostly just set
up for later payoffs like when she does
the Love Actually thing where she just
drops the signs with what they're saying
before things blow up again I was
surprised at how long she lingered
outside the door when natan vixen
started having sex and she activated her
totems probably one of the funniest
parts of the episode was by number seven
heat waves box just all the times that
Nate had to get killed so that they
could open it up to find out about heat
waves trashy sci-fi romance novel then
later finding out the sorry actually
read it oh it's actually really good and
it turns out that heatwave you know like
a lot of authors wrote himself into the
story
so when she says your protagonist needs
to embrace his new family she's just
talking about heatwave embracing the
people on the Waverider but I was really
happy number six that Rey made a
reference to that Star Trek episode
cause and effect because the legends
episode almost copy and pasted that
entire story they really just took the
framework of it like the reason for the
time loops in the Star Trek episode was
something different that was played more
for serious sci-fi the legends mostly
did it for comedy because it was all
happening inside saris head the whole
time
totally not surprised that Ray's a Star
Trek fan and it was fun to watch them
shrink down I forgot the sorry can fly
with her air totem but I think that's
mostly because they're saving special
effects money because wally west is
coming on and it's a little more
expensive to do flash effects so why I'm
totally fine with them skimping on
special effects the last couple of
episodes if it means they're gonna be
throwing a lot of money behind the rest
of the episodes this season number five
the fun loop also one of my favorite
parts of the episode she was playing
with items that the other people got
from previous seasons in the show going
all the way back to hawkgirl's mask in
season one she wears the Roman gear she
plays with worries heatwave Gunn got a
little serious though number four she
actually tries to legit kill herself it
doesn't work of course like it's not
like she's gonna leave the show this
early in the season Sara believes her
they all start working through it they
find Gary stuck in the trash compactor
hilarious reason for why he wound up in
there when we find out what Gideon did
in number three it wasn't till about
midway through her speech pontificating
to the group about what they meant to
her and how they should all just embrace
who they are be truthful tell everybody
what's going on tell Sara
about what
constantine told you so eventually they
just kept going on and on I'm like okay
wait a minute this is very clearly gonna
be played for comedy the bomb is not
gonna go off and sure enough the bomb
didn't go off but instead of like the
funny reaction from the group like oh
gosh I just bared my soul to the group
and now I have to live with them Gideon
walks out in real life form which is I
think the second time or the third time
that she's done it on the show they
don't do it very often but she walks out
and explains that it was just a
simulation in her head because the
computer program that Zoe had engineered
at the beginning of the episode really
did work but in order for her to be able
to change her timeline she had to stay
on the Waverider and she wasn't gonna do
that if things have proceeded normally
so Gideon in putting her through this
it's a wonderful life Groundhog's Day
simulation which is trying to do the
thing that sorry programmed her to do
and at the end of the day the funny
thing about Sarah - is hardcore she was
through the episode she tells Ari that
she's totally cool messing with the
timeline because of a technicality like
it's all in the interpretation well your
past is my future and I'm only allowed
to not change my past so that's her
saying that she's not gonna try and go
back and save earth one Laurel but she's
totally cool changing time to help sorry
save her brother so they'll do that by
the end of the season I'm sure but it
will mean them playing it fast and loose
with the timeline which you know dr. who
rules the doctor breaks a lot of his own
rules the whole time so it's never meant
to be the legends doing exactly what
they're supposed to do the whole idea is
if they're a bunch of screw-ups and they
make mistakes as they go along so there
will be changes to the timeline it'll be
really interesting to see how that
affects the Wally West character because
obviously Barry changing the timeline
was the whole basis for season 3 in
sabot R so imagine Wally's perspective
when he finds them trying to fix the
timeline like oh I could tell you guys
all about changing timelines
sit down legends and I shall tell you
the tale of Savitt R although I have a
feeling that at this point the legends
probably heard about what happens so
they probably kind of know about sabot R
but maybe Wally will tell them some
stories number one of course is rip
hunter freshly escaped from the time
Bureau prison to go recruit Wally West
who's in Yunnan Province just meditating
on life the meaning of everything in
while that isn't necessarily an easter
egg for anything like him being in unit
it was actually a flash story in Korea
where an entire town was going to be
blown up by an atomic bomb in the Wally
West version of the flash saved about a
half a million people by running faster
than the speed of light while the rest
of the Justice League was trying to
prevent a complete catastrophe in that
twist is actually the basis for the
flash episode 15 I've already done a
video for that so I'll just had a link
to that at the end of the video but
because flash actually just ran to China
if you're wondering if the same place
where Goldberg was is actually a
different place but let me know in the
comments what did you guys think of the
episode and what do you want to see them
do with the Wally West character given
Flash's ability to time travel and just
the idea that changing the timeline has
gone very very badly for the flash
family in the past all you have to do to
enter that blass ring giveaway is just
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
the video congratulations to the winner
from my last video this past weekend
Devin door please private message me so
I can get your contact details I'll name
a new winner when I post new flash this
week which should be in the next day or
two click here to learn about that flash
family episode with Jay Garrick and
Jesse quick and click here to learn
about the Captain Marvel Easter Egg
during the Black Panther movie thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight